hi there reject nation my name is Greg
Alba we are going to watch the final
season trailer of Jessica Jones oh this
would be the final of the Marvel Netflix
series I just finished the Punisher
season two like a week and a half ago I
actually liked it for the most part I've
seen Jessica Jones season 1 and 2 john
has not finished season 2 so that's why
I'm here by myself again if you guys
watch this channel you know that
sometimes we do page from the day shots
at the end of videos I wanted to do one
at the top of this video for a very
specific reason this one is for totally
jumbled however he wanted to dedicate it
to his friend Billy Laurence Billy
Laurence is a longtime follower of this
channel he's a really sweet guy even
said in like a video message not long
ago great great dude unfortunately his
mother is battling tumors at the moment
it's already taken a pretty big loss on
her own physical body they've had to
remove like a kidney a spleen a rib but
she's still battling through and of
course the medical expenses or you know
they're very expensive so there's a
GoFundMe page if you want to learn more
about it if you want to go show their
support go donate to help her survive
through this this terrible unfortunate
event that she's going through right now
there's a link in the description box
the link of the pin comment please read
up on it her name is candy Kaufman I
haven't personally met her of course no
TJ Billy they're great guys and I can
only assume the mother is just this
wonderful woman they've already raised a
couple thousand dollars these kinds of
medical treatments are way way more than
that so please go check it out and help
Billy's mom beat cancer anyway on to
Jessica Jones trailer
[Music]
cheater you were given every advantage
allowed the man half-snake after mistake
you can't control yourself you have no
discipline just brute force what do you
want I want you to die
it's not here cryptic attrition barely
survived again telling you did this
let's go get him
I don't need your help
he was unjustly arrested Oh expanding
him
[Music]
everybody's got a story a beginning a
middle and
[Music]
I'm late for work as what super cat
burglar you don't want just you do it
your way I'm gonna do it there's still a
way this ends with me respecting you
it's not my highest priority right now
Jessica Jones I love them you could run
the music
terrified
[Music]
[Laughter]
I give a [ __ ] what other people think
there you go
I got some thoughts first thought I
thought I escaped these noises when I
moved apartments and now they've come
back to haunt me
and I'm sorry it's in the background
right now I'm sad this is the final
season I loved the first season of
Jessica Jones a lot the second season
that first half was really rough to get
through honestly I thought it was very
boring but I actually really like the
last half of it spoilers if you're
watching the third season trailer I
might talk about something that happens
in the second season the last half of
season 2 I actually liked a lot I was
very much pulled in throughout Krysten
Ritter is phenomenal as always it's like
the show is at its best when it's
focusing on its main character the idea
of her and Trish working together right
now does not particularly excite me the
end of season 2 with Trish Walker
I really really hated I don't know the
actresses name I remember I've thought
my head I don't think the actress is bad
I think she's actually a really good
actress I don't like the writing of
Trish I think the writers hate her I
just get that vibe they don't they just
don't like that character because she's
insanely unlikable through especially
the last half of season 2 and when she
kills Jess's mom at the end I just could
not like I didn't do a reaction to it
I was watched by myself but I was I was
there just like what oh I can't believe
this and then they kind of give her this
cool button moment where what does she
like dropped something and catches it in
a cool way right I forget what it was I
just remember thinking she didn't earn
that cool moment I'm not excited for her
to be Hellcat and she still seems like
she's got some attitude problems from
like a flicker of dialogue here in this
trailer with her talk
about like you do it you're away I'm
into my way Jess and I'm like you your
way seems to just screw things up
constantly I'm not exactly excited for
Trish and Jess to be working together
I'm kind of surprised jess is working
with her but yeah I mean they grew up
together whatever either way you know
like I said the actress does a really
good job of what she's given she's great
but the character itself not a big fan
of as far as this trailer goes I love
the trailer music in here that type of
suspenseful mystery kind of horror
aesthetic music I really did enjoy and I
also think they're doing a great call
and they must have listened to a lot of
the criticism that last season God about
having a more focused central villain
this Salinger character I think is a
great choice he seems like a like a
genius sort of psychopath they seem to
be having the main storylines all
linking you got Jess and Trish going
after him he's obsessed with Jessica
Jones but then this idea of like
carrie-anne moss is Jerry defending
Salinger makes it very essential because
one of the issues I have was season two
was it kind of felt like we had a lot of
storylines in a bunch of different
directions and the only truly gripping
one was the Jessica Jones storyline but
we had all these like different swerving
around and it took a long time to build
I imagine this season it's the same
length as the other seasons I really
hope that it doesn't feel like it's
being dragged out or stretched out
because I didn't it's not Jessica Jones
exclusively I felt the Punisher season 2
had that most of the Netflix seasons
have that even though I love or like
pretty much like I can't think of one of
the the seasons of any of these shows
that I just did not like I really hope
that it doesn't take too long to you
know get to some awesome stuff but this
film looks good pushing Jess to this
like deeper darker depth you know this
theme of like hero or fraud I find
fascinating Jessica Jones out of all of
the the defenders I mean hell even the
Punisher by season 2 is viewed as more
of a hero for like New York City then
the identity of Jessica Jones as well
it's one of the cool things about
jessica jones though is she has like
missions
that she assigns herself to or she is
assigned to she's not ever really viewed
as a hero I know she eventually ends
kilgrave in season one but that was just
like a very personal nemesis for her and
that was a personal kill for her that
just happened to translate it to being a
you know a hero for the people but in
season two you don't really get much of
that as like a hero for the people
considering that this is the last season
and I think they had the benefit of
knowing this time around because it
seems like what the other Marvel Netflix
shows they ultimately didn't know that
they were gonna be canceled and I think
they were still filming this when they
pretty much figured out oh this is this
is gonna be the final season so we
should probably try to end this in a way
word this could be a you know an ending
chapter closed the book on Jessica Jones
just in case they decide not to bring
back Kristin Ritter's Jessica Jones or
any of the other Netflix Marvel cast you
know I'm trans like I think it would be
cool if they did and this season on a
note she just come into being a hero
that she views herself as someone who is
also a hero in some degree I don't want
her to do like some superhero pose or
whatever had like rock some cost to you
but she's always been at crossroads
between that she seems to have these
villains who seem to you know capitalize
on a lot of her past and her flaws she
ultimately never feels like she is a
protector for the people it would be
cool to kind of shift her identity there
that way I feel like it would be a
complete arc
you know like season one that's a big
part of what Trish is always trying to
tell her is that you could be a hero she
doesn't want to be it and then by the
end of this season she is like oh she is
a hero she is a defender you know what I
mean unless someone arguing me on that
they might not agree with that point but
I feel like for the character of Jessica
that it would be cool for her to feel
that way by the end of it all I guess my
last thing is she must not be with that
Hispanic dude from season 2 the guy had
a kid that's too bad I thought they got
along pretty well he was hot I don't
really care anyway guys did you like
Jessica Jones season 2 are you excited
for this final season are you gonna miss
the show leave a comment down below you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell if you like
this video
hit the like button also check us out on
patreon we do weekly Q&A s TV show
reaction stream alongs for many many
shows some with reaction highlights
included go to our patreon page to find
out what that's all about and we'll
catch you guys soon